bonjour et bienvenue dans l'entretien de
france 24 c'est un homme qui a parcouru
le monde suivant le fil des conflits et
de restructuration des pays en
décryptant les gestes des hommes de
pouvoir qui façonnent les guerres puis
l'épée mais aussi sur le terrain pour
écouter les hommes et les femmes qui
subissent les aléas épouse les causes ou
adaptent leur quotidien pour faire
survivre leur famille gérard chaliand
bonjour bonjour vous publiez vos
mémoires le savoir de la peau les quatre
dernières décennies de géopolitique
raconté vous êtes allé au kurdistan en
arménie en amérique du sud vous avez
observé deux colosses face à face les
états unis et la russie est votre venue
coïncide évidemment avec la guerre en
ukraine alors avec un peu de recul
quelques jours de recul sur le
déclenchement cette décision de vladimir
poutine est ce qu'elle vous étonne
toujours ou est ce qu'elle vous semble
finalement augurer cet affrontement des
de la politique russe à titre personnel
je pensais qu ils gesticulaient je vois
qu'il va beaucoup plus loin ceci dit je
comprends son point de vue
au lendemain de la guerre froide les
états unis ont véritablement décidé de
repousser l'ex urss ou frontières de la
russie dernier acte l'ukraine où ça a
été saisi de l'autre côté comme quelque
chose peu acceptable particulièrement à
la perspective d'avoir à la fois la
géorgie et d'ukraine passante dans
l'escarcelle de l'otan bon alors il
s'est préparé
effectivement est-ce qu'il n'a pas
sous-estimer l'épaisseur du patriotisme
et craignent un je crois que oui il ya
aucun doute là dessus alors vous êtes
géostratège vous avez l'habitude d'aller
dans ces différents pays qu'est ce que
vous avez ressenti et les dernières fois
que vous êtes allé en ukraine vous êtes
dans le vif par exemple année à odessa
ça vous dit quelque chose sur
l'occidentalisation de l'ukraine va
écouter d'abord l'ukraine fait partie de
l'europe il ya même la partie s'ils
voulaient occidentale c'est à dire le
vif qui est totalement catholiques
puisqu'elle est attaché à rome
ils ont appartenu essentiellement un
vieil empire enfin qui était lituanie
aux polonais donc c'est totalement
l'europe de surcroît par exemple
odessa c'est une architecture habsbourg
gh c'est à dire souhaite comme à
budapest coma comme dans la capitale de
la tchéquie voilà l'objet dans le 19ème
tout à fait être tout à fait ben oui ça
existe alors par contre le régime que
j'ai rencontré l'année dernière était un
régime qui n'était pas particulièrement
comment dirais-je
pas véritablement populaire on estimait
qu'il y avait trop d'oligarques ceux qui
s'étaient battus et j'en connais
estimait qu'il s'est battu pour ça qu'il
y avait de la corruption et je leur
région deux autres corruption en ukraine
c'est souvent le terme je leur ai je
répondu qu'est-ce qu'il n'est pas
corrompue dans l'ex urss tout la russie
pour commencer
donc il faut pas s'étonner et il ya une
chose certaine vous pouvez ne pas avoir
un élan du coeur pour le régime qui est
le vôtre mais par contre voir un voisin
veut dire vous dire ce qui est bon pour
vous c'est une autre paire de manches
ils ont refusé ça ils se sentent
ukrainien ils se sentent patriotes ils
ne veulent pas qu'on leur vie ce qui est
bon pour eux
là en ce moment où la millière poutine
fait une vraie guerre il a assiégé des
villes il a assiégé marioupol il la
regarde kiev évidemment caire kif au
dessin on a tous la carte en tête
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il va vouloir
absolument retenir selon vous qu'est-ce
que vous parliez qu'il avait quelque
chose à montrer à l'occident en disant
c'est ma ligne rouge bon d'une part il
montre effectivement que on ne manipule
pas si aisément par contre il nous a pas
dit quels sont les buts de guerre il n'a
pas dit voilà ce que je veux et à ceux à
cette condition là je me retire alors
est-ce qu'il veut mettre à bas le régime
d'où l'encerclement de la capitale il
peut essayer de le décapiter ou alors il
peut se contenter de la partie
véritablement russe c'est à dire le
donetsk lellouche ans le dombass
et puis une petite avancée vers la mer
en direction de donner ça mais s'en
prendre aux dessins bon on va voir ceci
dit le poids des sanctions est
considérable
l'équipe est de toute façon va lui
coûter très cher à nous aussi d'ailleurs
et il va falloir pour lui s'extirper de
cette affaire sans paraître avoir perdu
alors il lui reste encore des moyens
c'est à dire c'est que c'est lui qui met
quand même l'offensive mais la contre
offensive se prépare il ya des armes qui
pénètrent à travers la pologne des armes
anti-aériennes les armes anti tank bas
tout ça ça va faire mal aux soldats qui
sont sur place par les soldats russes et
la guerre va se trouver montée d'un cran
donc l'europe plus soudé finalement face
à ce conflit qu on pouvait l'imaginer et
qui arment mieux ainsi que les
américains l'ukraine est ce qu'on
constate c'est que les européens pour
une fois on dit non de façon claire
n'ont pas dit c'est inadmissible mais je
l'admets non ils ont dit non les
allemands ont changé isabelle qui
veulent faire un effort sur le plan
militaire
d'autres comme les finlandais qui
voulaient rester le plus neutre possible
et biens et s'engage il ya quelque chose
de nouveau qui se passe en europe alors
est-ce qu'on va être capables de nous
réinventer quelque chose qui nous
unissent davantage parce que le
parapluie américain bubba c'est fini
c'est pas qu'il soit fini à jamais enfin
ils l'ont dit carrément nous notre
problème c'est d'abord contré les
chinois qui sont le problème principal
pour nous américains et pour nous
occidentaux d'ailleurs par la même
occasion mais la russie pose un problème
bon il ya des gens comme les turcs par
exemple avec monsieur renaud a comme
monsieur poutine qui estime qu'
aujourd'hui avec le relatif déclin de
l'occident il ya des places à prendre
pour les puissances moyennes avec un
rayonnement bon les pays baltes juste je
finis là dessus parce que les pays
baltes qui se sentent aussi dans le
collimateur ce pareil c'est des pays que
vous avez sillonné ça ce sont des pays
qui resteront européen quoi qu'il arrive
ou qui ont aussi une capacité abandonné
à se faire capter oui je connais tu
allais le jeu codé riga maison des
droits parapluie de l'otan certes mais
quel est leur coeur
ils ont toujours craint l'union
soviétique parce que
ils ont été peuplée d'un bon tiers de
russes c'était une chose totalement
nouvelle autrefois c'était plutôt les
allemands c'est à dire que cette partie
là a toujours été un enjeu aujourd'hui
ils tiennent beaucoup ont fait d'être
rattachée à l'otan d'être rattachée à
l'europe à mon sens il n'y a pas
d'inquiétude à avoir monsieur poutine a
suffisamment de problèmes avec l'ukraine
pour part en chercher dans les pays
baltes alors vous avez décrit cette
frange européenne je vous ramène
effectivement vers l'ancien empire
ottoman dont vous commenciez à parler
face à vladimir poutine on a aussi un
air dogan qui s'est joué sur toutes les
facettes en fait avec les detroit en ce
moment il est à la fois ami ennemi de
vladimir poutine il fait quoi elle avait
parfaitement raison c'est un monsieur
qui joue sur plusieurs tableaux qui
s'intéresse évidemment d'abord à ses
intérêts stricte et il en a des gros il
se souvient que l' empire ottoman a été
présent très longtemps pendant environ
six siècles et dont une partie de
l'europe balkanique il se souvient aussi
que les jeunes turcs avaient le
sentiment que jusqu'à la frontière
chinoise tout ceci était turcophone
alors ils jouent les deux tableaux à la
fois il a marqué des points en libye par
exemple avec ses drones il s'est
installé de façon sérieuse il a des
drones en ukraine il a des gros dans
l'ukraine et alors là justement comme il
avait beaucoup flirté avec les russes
avec les 16 20 les ss 400 ce qui
déplaisait beaucoup aux états unis mais
il s'est rattrapé en offrant des drones
aux ukrainiens qui sont parus évidemment
décidé à autre chose que contre les
russes bon donc guillou sur les deux
tableaux et c'était un peu à choper
aussi avec les russes sur la question
que vous connaissez bien puisque vous
êtes un grand spécialiste de l'arménie
quand il ya eu l'affrontement avec le
haut karabagh en fait sans déchets en
effet là il disputait aux ruches une
région qui est considéré comme faisant
partie de ce qu'ils appellent le proche
étranger
et dans lequel il estime que c'est eux
les patrons géorgie azerbaïdjan arménie
et c'est alors ils vont s'entendre ils
vont se détester
eh bien ça les empêche pas d'être de
continuer à être amis il l'a dit mais
par exemple il a aussi montré que
j'estime at-il dit que les russes
devraient faire la paix et est rentré
dans le rang donc c'est un copain il
reste un signe pour les états unis
redisant je n'oublie pas que je suis
encore membre de l'otan et que je n'ai
pas l'intention d'en sortir d'autant
plus que ça me protège donc monsieur
andorrane jouent toutes les cartes à la
fois en essayant de consolider son
pouvoir son talon d'achille
c'est son économie
ses finances vont mal le tourisme ça ne
marche plus très bien
il fait comme poutine il a tout misé sur
l'armement c'est à dire aujourd'hui
c'est très difficile de contester la
turquie parce que ils ont les moyens de
se défendre alors on fait justement la
jonction vers la fin cet entretien il ya
un autre pays qui s'est jouée à de
médiation c'est la chine qui propose
d'avoir ce rôle politique qu'elle
n'avait pas jusqu'à présent c'était un
rôle économique est-ce que vous pensez
que on va de plus en plus glisser vers
cet axe asiatiques qui va peser tâche
est de l'europe
ç'a eu pour poutine qu'ils gagnent ou
qu'ils perdent il a besoin des chinois
qu'ils gagnent ou qu'ils perdent des
sanctions il va les payer qui va alléger
les sanctions
les chinois les chinois regardent ce qui
se passe ils n'ont pas condamné au
contraire ils ont dit bon on est à vos
côtés ils n'ont pas crié très fort parce
que c'est pas la peine mais ils se
disent attention si on attaque sur
taïwan voilà ce qui nous attend donc les
chinois voient tout cela de très près
ils savent qu'en fin de compte il pèse
de plus en plus pour les états unis ils
sont l'unique problème sérieux et pour
monsieur
poutine s'est lui lic bouée de sauvetage
est ce que demain on pourra voir des
russes qui adorait l'europe se dire
finalement que passer des vacances du
côté de l'asie envoyer leurs enfants
étudier du côté de singapour ce sera
l'avenir
pour moi
la russie c'est l'europe
leur grand écrivain tolstoï dostoïevski
tout ça c'est l'europe c'est la maison
ils nous ont regardés celle qui
parlaient français jusqu'à 1917 d'autre
part leurs populations se trouve du côté
de ce qu'on appelle la russie d'europe à
85% il ya 15% maximum dans cet immense
sibérie bon alors nous vous riez à nous
ne les avons pas à tirer nous nous avons
été en fin de compte manipulés par les
américains on aurait dû être plus
prudent avec les russes conservé des
liens et finalement on les a poussés
vers les chinois eh bien je marche
arrière en je vous remercie de cet
entretien le savoir de la peau et votre
livre qui sort et le génocide des
arméniens en 1915 est en ré édition
poche vous êtes donc très présent en
librairie bonne suite de programmes sur
france 24
[Musique]